últimamente he estado más preocupado
acerca de mi salud
he decidido contar el número de calorías
que consumo durante el día así que
digamos que ese es el número
de calorías
que consumo en un día
y quiero consumir menos de 1500 calorías
al día como podría escribir esto como
una desigualdad osea que sé el número de
calorías sea menor que digamos en 1500
esto es que se sea menor
recuerda ya trabajamos con el signo
menor que y el signo menor que apunta
hacia la cantidad menor o sea así como
lo vemos esto es c es menor que 1500
si en un día pues yo no consumo calorías
o sea cero calorías o 200 calorías o 450
calorías pues efectivamente todos esos
valores para se cumplen que se es menor
que 1500 pero qué pasa con el 1500 qué
tal si consumo 1.500 mil 500
es menor que 1500 pues no verdad 1500 no
es menor que 1500 y este enunciado no es
verdadero
así que déjame quitarlo
el asunto al que quiero llegar es
considerar el 1500 también o sea en esta
expresión que yo tengo aquí el valor de
ese tiene que ser menor que 1500 sin
incluir al 1500 cómo puedo yo escribir
esto que se permita también el 1500 para
hacer eso lo que voy a hacer es dibujar
una línea debajo del símbolo menor que y
ahora ya no es el signo menor que si no
es el signo menor o igual que a ver
déjame escribirlo o sea este signo ahora
quiere decir que es menor
o
igual
qué
ahora puedo tener todos los valores
menores que 1500 incluyendo el 1500 cómo
puedo mostrar esto en la recta numérica
veamos voy a poner mi recta numérica
es decir la recta numérica es esta que
está aquí digamos que el 0 está aquí y
que el 1500 está aquí voy a indicar el
1500 con este punto observa que lo estoy
rellenando es un círculo relleno y
después voy a colorear todos los valores
menores al 1500 absolutamente todos los
que son menores a 1500 porque todos esos
son válidos para nuestra desigualdad y
esta es una forma de representar esta
desigualdad que se es menor o igual que
1500 en la recta numérica pero quisiera
regresar al caso inicial que teníamos el
cual decía que se es menor o sea que las
calorías son menores que 1500 común
representaría ello esta desigualdad en
la recta numérica entonces otra vez voy
a poner
médica
otra vez por aquí está el 0 y el 1500
digamos que está por acá
observa que para representar en la recta
numérica esta desigualdad en este caso
ahora el 1500 lo voy a indicar con un
círculo que no está relleno
esto quiere decir que no está
contemplado en 1500 y después voy a
colorear todos los valores menores de
1500 que son válidos para la de 50 y
bien ahora me vas a decir ya vimos el
caso para menor o igual que ya vimos el
caso para menor que como puedo
representar otros casos en la recta
numérica digamos casos en los que se
utiliza el mayor que bien a ver vamos
hacer un poco de espacio voy a hacer
espacio para ahora trabajar estos brazos
y siguiendo con el tema de la salud
también me gustaría controlar la
cantidad de agua que digamos que a
es igual al número de litros de agua
al igual que consumó al día
y me puse a hacer una investigación y
encontré que debo de beber más de dos
litros de agua al día que el agua que
tomo el día tiene que ser mayor de 2
litros como represento esto en la recta
numérica bien pues otra vez voy a pintar
la recta numérica
digamos que aquí está el cero digamos
que aquí está el 2
y en este caso en el que debo de beber
más de dos litros de agua al día
entonces voy a indicar el 2 con un
círculo sin relleno y lo observas porque
no está permitido el valor 2 y de ahí
voy a pintar todos los valores mayores
que 2
y esta es la manera de representar esta
desigualdad en la recta numérica pero
qué pasa si quiero ser un poco permisivo
e incluir el caso de beber dos litros de
agua es decir tener la situación que a
sea mayor o igual que 2
bueno pues otra vez voy a pintar mi
recta numérica
digamos que aquí está el cero digamos
que por acá está el 2
y ahora voy a indicar el 2 con un
círculo relleno esto quiere decir que el
valor de 2 está permitido y después voy
a indicar coloreando todos los valores
que son mayores que 2